so let's look at it from uk's side i'll
be uki
uh this is not what you're doing
nor is he initiating his uh a strike
okay but he initiates the strike
why why can't i do that of course i
could right
he initiates the strike that's more like
what if training
and kihon does not keep on okay
so uh i'm
coming in with a full-on
bone it has enough penetration to cut
through his body and down to his heart
okay so don't start
what happens is because he catches it
going up you see
you start just doing this do you see
that
he he has to do it so uh
first we're just gonna practice this uh
technique okay so i'm coming in boom i
hit
down through his sternum and down to the
end of the cut like kitty rush okay
so not uh showmance booty
kitty arrows okay
[Music]
so boom pop pop
okay let's try so uh again when you're
punching it's a beginner mistake that
you're punching range is
what is out here you see then that
becomes your mind
but that's not that's not true punching
range okay
so my punching range is going to be
closer
boom okay so if you pay attention
uh on the other one my foot hits
boom then my strike hits but on a real
punch my foot is still moving
at the moment it makes con at moment
touches
but very similar here is a lot of you
think
that the stance should stop when the
strike
but that's not true okay so
now when you're being asked to knock him
down
with kitty at us you're all i don't know
where to step
so you're like his body's in the his
body is not gonna be there
you understand so there's a displacement
my stance is coming
in boom do you see so the knee drops
home when i'm hitting somewhere around
uh showmance buddy
just prior to kireiro just like any item
so you you're moving him body's moving
through
okay try it again so it's this
up part that he should already start
moving his sword should already go to
his last sword
if he is uh trying to address my sword
on its young phase but other ones should
just
continue do you got it don't start
turning yourself
it's not your job to turn yourself it's
his job to turn you
okay so he has to catch it going up
home and when he catches it going up
i don't retreat so i'm not going here
i'm going
[Music]
i have to reconcile his union young
energy
so i do i'm still here
i'm still in this fight
not like this
so he's training in you did young
reconciliation
from the young perspective as nagit
but i'm saying in unity on
reconciliation
from the yin perspective as you can i
still have to reconcile yin
and yang so i'm going in boom he
continues
because he has to go back one step
if we're here like this it looks to you
maybe
like he has the advantage he does not
have the advantage yet okay
we're still here he uh can't come
forward
you see he uh he has to deal with
these kicks boom he can't mount
can't okay he has to reconcile the arm
so i go in home and i'm still
alive the more he pushes this
collapses because go this is bracey
he goes and i'm yielding you see still
in it
still aggressive still
trying to kick his ass okay so when he
feels
all those openings that i have he's
going to want to close my shoulder off
so that's what he does he closes my
shoulder
again no because he didn't close it all
the way
so he goes around there he got it
so my body doesn't unlock
whoa he's going still reconciling
still alive
ugh
so
yes okay so
usually what happens in training as as
he goes
go and uh this part here
is people will go unconscious as the
situation changes
okay so you'll feel
this kind of deadness here
well that's your yin opening that's your
what you reconcile
so he goes who's dead come on
you're on
you should not receive an ego if your
kid does that
okay your job is to reconcile so not go
like this
you see that is this this moves over
here now
they're in home it's dead it just come
on
you can go knee on belly too right and
then over
okay let's go okay so as you're going in
the keyhole
you always have this this feeling
this feeling of go getting to his body
but you feel
he's got his ik adhesion and his cocky
integrity there that you know you're not
going to get there
you see you know i can feel all i know
it's not going to get there so i'm gonna
take this angle do you see
i go into the empty space all right but
my intention is not to attack the arm
my intention is always to fight the guy
fight the archer not the arrow
okay so we're going
oh i'm going i'm going into him do you
see
wait i think i got you you see
get it there you go okay then i go this
way
when i come around
make sure you're here on you're not just
floating around this
perimeter you're you're coming in
i'm going to get you again it's too open
okay then
see i step in here you see that
difference
there you go in here that's the free
space and then you come
but my attention is him not his arm
tension is him
i just go to the arm because he covered
himself
this way this woman then in
[Music]
him him kim is right i got you again
close there you go in okay
now we'll look at the last part where he
uh dies so
after i get here he dies it's the same
thing
you just let him die go on to his back
these knees go into his scapula come
underneath his chin
pull up on his chin as you press down on
his on the scalp
you'll feel the end opening he took his
arm out of the fight
so you go one two he just dies on you go
immediately
come up here
you don't want to get in the habit he
dies and you pick up the hand
and you come around for the last step he
has to do something
for you to reconcile something so you
feel
that you didn't poop just on his back
right away
down here
and here like this you can get his hair
at first then go to the chin
cut that chin with the chin strap
he dies it's immediate you see that's
your guitar
okay so okay does not give those two
openings so i'm the okay again
i'm doing my thing he goes
inside of the arm
so
[Music]
me
i never give those two openings
otherwise your motto makes no sense